All the stuff that gets thrown on
western nations and how they have to
accept it like you have to suppress your
culture, your heritage, your religion.
What other country does that to host
some other people? Who does that?
Nobody. Why is it always the west that
has to do it?
>> So when you present people with this
argument that there are actually Muslim
slave traders and a lot of them who took
a significant number of white people,
what is the response? Why is there like
a right-wing or a leftwing policy as
opposed to an evidence policy? So, for
example, data is not right or left like
global climate data is not right.
There's just data. What you do with the
data in terms of your public policy that
is inherently political.
>> That's I think one of the biggest
problems nowadays is we are trapped in
this left right spectrum.
>> I think that should give us courage
exposure to other people's perspectives.
It's moving us in a good direction.
So, there's a lot of controversy with
the St. George's flag and Islamic
immigration, and I'm hoping that you can
give us some historical clarity on this.
What's what's going on?
>> Yeah, good question, Peter. Um, so the
background, the context is that in the
UK or England, the St. George flag,
which is white with a red cross,
>> right?
>> And which hails back primarily, I think,
to Edward I, you know, from the movie
Braveheart, Long Shanks, the bad guy who
tortures all the the Scots.
>> He's actually he was a he was one of the
last crusaders as well. Um anyway,
>> the what I understand what's going on
now is a lot of Brits are gravitating
towards that flag. And as to why,
there's various reasons, but mostly
mostly it's connected to I think the
migrant crisis, of course.
>> Oh, interesting. Okay. So, it's being
seen and being portrayed as a sort of
right-wing radical right-wing thing. And
yet, to me, it's kind of interesting
because when you see the interplay
between that flag and history, there's
actually a very interesting continuity.
So, as I alluded earlier, the uh the St.
George flag with the red cross on white
goes all the way back to the um to the
crusader era. And in fact, it's very
much similar to the Templar flag, the
flag of the Knights of the Temple. And
it was founded right around the same
time. They're they're found founded
around 1119 and Edward, you know, adopts
that flag right around I want to say
right around uh late 1200s. But what's
interesting about it is the red
indicates martyrdom. Okay, so these are
these these are the Christians who are
dying for their faith against
historically Muslims in the Holy Land
during the Crusades. And the white would
often symbolize purity. So I'm trying to
live a righteous lifestyle, but at the
same time, I'm willing to go to war and
fight for my faith. And that of course
there's so much that can be said about
that. On the one hand, it's uh it
typified early premodern medieval
Christianity. On the other hand, it's so
kind of uh poo pooed nowadays by
especially modern Christians. It's such
a horrible thing. And yet, I think we're
seeing people gravitate back to it
>> because they find the appeal. And a lot
of them probably don't even realize how
connected these flags were to the fight
with Muslims. And yet here they are
again, Muslims in their own lands. is in
the UK, right? And uh and and the flag
is coming back as part of the national
kind of uh resistance.
>> So the the people who are it's my
understanding that primarily the people
who are taking down the flags,
government officials because they say
it's unsa unsafe,
>> right?
>> So I'm I'm a little unclear. So the
historical context for that is I'm Can
you Can you fill me in a little more,
please? Well, what they're basically
saying is, you know, it's very natural
for any people to want to gravitate to
the banners of their forefathers or or
the flags in this case, the St. George
flag. And in every other context, no one
would complain about it. It makes sense.
People, they're patriots. They're good,
right? They like their heritage, their
culture. Uh in the UK and other Western
nations, of course, that's a bad thing
to do because those countries no longer
have their heritage to maintain because
they've been sold out to others, to all
these migrants from the Islamic world.
So obviously if you cling to the flag of
St. George or anything that is
distinctly British or English,
>> you're a Nazi.
>> You're an evil person. Yeah. Because
you're supposed to give that up now and
embrace multiculturalism, which of
course never works for the native people
of Europe.
>> Do the people So they want I don't know
who the they is in that sentence, but
the elites, the politicians.
So, somebody wants a more multicultural
society, but the people,
and please, please push back or correct
me if I'm wrong. I'm just throwing this
out. This is not my area of expertise.
But the people for whom multiculturalism
like they've accepted, they don't accept
multiculturalism. Like, they don't want
multiculturalism.
>> You mean the people who come in? Yeah.
>> Of course not. Because multiculturalism
is a one-way street. It's only meant to
accommodate and help the outsiders and
weaken the insiders. Uh
>> so, so what like what percentage of
people is it possible to know a number?
Because there are many people, many
Muslims, and please, please push back or
correct me if I'm wrong,
>> who really do live in harmony with the
host population. They're not blowing
shit up. They're
>> not demanding parallel courts. They're
not chopping anybody sawing anybody's
head off with a rusty butter knife.
They're like,
>> so what percentage of people are we
talking about? Well, that's the
question, right? And that's the
difficult question. And it depends on
who you ask, but whatever the even let's
let's give it a very conservative
number, very small number. The smallest
number I've ever heard even from
apologists who will say, "No, no, most
Muslims will say 10%." Right?
>> But that's still a problem, right? If
you've got multi many millions of Muslim
migrants in Europe and only 10% are
going to blow themselves up or slaughter
you or rape your children, that's still
a big problem, isn't it? Um, so I agree
that a lot of them are not necessarily
doing this. A lot of them are in it for
a good life. A lot of them just are
doing whatever they can. But
>> Okay. So I I know you're not the kind of
guy I have to risk offending, but I'm
going to say it anyway.
>> Why should anybody in the US care
>> about Europe? You mean?
>> Well, yeah. I mean, I understand why the
people over there should care. I guess
to an extent I do. To an extent, I
really don't care because they don't
care about themselves. So why? But why
should we care about what happens if
they be like why should who I mean in
the America United States we're sick of
it. We're we have debts. We have
>> homeless problems, fentanyl problems, we
have
>> Why should we care?
>> Well, I don't think your average
American cares about it. I don't think
they even care about
>> they don't care about the map. Yeah.
Yeah. I I I don't think they care at
all. I think the only lesson or the
instruction in what's happening to the
UK is it's sort of a window into what
America could look like in the future
because uh let's just put it this way,
Europe, Western Europe is much more
progressive. So they they tend to reach
certain progressive uh um benchmarks
before the US does. And here's where
it's at. So if you look at countries
like Sweden, the UK, uh other
Scandinavian nations, but Sweden is
obviously the worst. Uh Germany, all of
them really, you know, Austria, Italy,
Spain, because I follow this very
closely. Um you know, again, it it's not
necessarily all of the migrants. That
would be a complete, you know, bed, but
it's a small percentage, but you it's
still havoc what they're doing.
>> Okay. So correct me if I'm wrong, but
it's my understanding, for example, we
take a different kind of migrant. So
Pakistani migrants in this country are
far more successful than Pakistani
migrants in Western Europe. So it's the
type of migrants that Western Europe is
taking in is that
>> well you know what I think it is also a
large part of it is it's the numbers. So
in the US there's smaller numbers that
come in of migrants of Muslims and so
with the smaller the number is the
larger the chance it'll actually
assimilate in the melting pot. But what
happens in Europe is they go there
immediately and they get into a ghetto.
They're all Pakistanis or they're all
whatever Syrians, they're all from
Morocco and they just live their way. So
they never change and they're almost
like a parasite in the host culture that
never assimilates. But I think in
America it's a little different because
the numbers are take me for example. You
know my family's from Egypt. When I was
born here um I didn't know any
Egyptians. You know, I mean, I it was
very rare, very I'm Coptic, so in the
Coptic church, we'd go and um I'd know a
few, but we moved around a lot, and it
was very often we'd go I'd go years. I
didn't know any. I wouldn't meet them.
Now, um you know, there's places in in
here in New Jersey, for example, I I was
there the other day, and it's like they
have a little Egypt and it's again, it's
all Egyptians and Egyptians. So, when
you have that, it becomes very difficult
for people to assimilate because they
stay within their tribe and they never
change.
>> Okay. So what is the problem with
a large number of for example Egyptian
Muslims or Somali Muslims? Maybe that's
I know I realized that's quite different
after I said it. But what is the problem
with a large number of these individuals
living in a host country not
assimilating?
>> Well the fundamental problem is we have
to go again to what does Islam teach?
Islam is inherently tribalistic. So the
first thing you have to understand that
to the Muslim he grows up it's all about
being loyal to my my thing which is
fellow Muslims right and there's
subcategories you know my family and
etc. But the the non-Muslim is de facto
enemy. Has always been.
>> Do you know that during the Middle Ages
if you were going to travel to the
caliphate from Europe because you're
going to have an embassy with the khalif
or the sultan, you're being sent by an
emperor. You had to have a special
permit because to say you're not to get
killed because if you were just a
regular European entering Muslim lands,
that means you're dead. You're enslaved
or killed on site. Okay? So that was the
mentality. If few people understand that
and it still carries over till today
whether whether if you're a radical then
of course it does because it's an actual
doctrine that you have to hate and war
and try to subvert the infidel. But even
if you're not a radical it carries in as
part of this sort of tribalistic
worldview that many Muslims have. It's
us against them. And tribalism of course
transcends religion. But it's really
very much uh we even had that that one
discussion before but it's very much
part of the religion of Islam because
what Muhammad did is he basically
deified tribalism. He took the concept
of us against them, but he turned it
into a religious thing, no longer a
blood ethnic thing. Okay? And that's
just how it's been throughout history.
So when you bring large groups of
Egyptians or Somalis who are Muslim and
they don't assimilate and inherently
they have this us against them,
>> Yeah.
>> Well, obviously that's not a good thing.
And your average American or European is
more, you know, grows up in this sort of
civic society idea and we're all trying
to help each other. And I give you the
benefit of the doubt. So you can easily
see who's going to be prayed upon and uh
uh you know exploited very easily and
that's kind of what we're happening
we're seeing.
>> Does it make a difference which country
the Muslim immigrants come from? Like if
they're from Indonesia, if they're from
>> Dubai
city, but if you know if they're from
does it make a difference?
>> Sure. I think there's you know there's
enough room for nuance for cultural
differences and ethnic differences. um
even if they're all Muslim because and I
I see that in my own studies when I look
at various countries. Okay. Um but still
it's it's still interesting to note that
I'll tell you I'll give you an example.
So Indonesia is always seen as a very
moderate Muslim nation. Right.
>> Correct.
>> And then another country like uh
Wahhabi, Saudi Arabia or Afghanistan
will be seen as very radical.
>> Now I every month I follow the
persecution of Christians in Islamic
lands and it they always follow
patterns. It's a
>> fulltime job.
>> Yeah, it is. It's a full-time job. But
the the persecution manifests itself in
various patterns which of course are go
back to Islamic teaching. So attacks on
churches because churches should not be
built for example. Um and what I find
ironically is it's across the board. So
>> what do you mean across the board?
>> In other words, the persecution will
happen also in Indonesia and it'll
happen in Saudi Arabia and it'll happen
in Nigeria. So what I'm saying is that
if you look at, you know, the multitude
of Muslim nations there, you got black
Muslims, you got white Muslims, you
know, Central Asian, Turkish, which look
rather white, Syrians, Lebanese, you
have East Asian, Sinaic, Indonesian, uh,
etc., Arabs, of course, and they all
have their own different cultures and
their own languages and their own
socioeconomic, political systems, right?
And yet when I when I focus in on this
question of what happens to Christians,
they all do the same exact thing.
>> Is there any Muslim
country in which Christians are not
persecuted.
>> I don't think
>> I guess it depends what you mean by
persecuted.
>> Yeah. But I'll tell you, okay, so let's
not even leave it up to me. There's an
organization known as Open Doors. It's a
human rights organization. It's been
around for decades. And every year they
publish an annual report called the
World Watch List. Okay? And it lists 50
nations where Christians are being
persecuted. Okay? And I I look at this
every year. I analyze it and I write
about it. And those 50 nations
habitually 37 is the numbers in my head
will be Muslim nations. Okay? So there's
what 200 at least nations in the world
and this is looking at the 50 worse and
37 are Muslim nations. Now I don't know
if that's every single Muslim nation uh
or not but I mean that's the vast
majority of
>> are atheists persecuted there as well
>> or they're just no open atheists. So
they just deny
>> atheism doesn't stand out the way
Christianity would. you know, atheists
don't go to a temple to celebrate
atheism, right?
>> Bad atheist, bad atheist.
>> It's hard to tell who's the atheist, you
know.
>> Um, okay. So, and the idea is, okay,
again, correct me if I'm wrong, but the
thinking was when there's some kind of
turmoil in Syria or what have you, and
when we import people, they're going to
assimilate and adopt the values of the
host country and we'll be in Shangala.
Everything's going to be fine. Is that
the thinking? It's like,
>> yeah, that's the thinking they've sold
to people and people have bought and
believed until they've seen the
opposite. Let let me let me pause you
right now and say I would love to have
someone on the show who disagrees with
you. Can you and I'm going to give
whoever you say I'm giving an open
invitation to. Can you think of anyone
on who disagrees with you?
>> Well, uh it depends on what you mean
because I write my primarily about
history. If you're talking about
history, um
>> someone who can make it popular and
understandable to people.
>> Well, there's this one guy and I think
his name is uh Roy Cassandra or
Cassandra. You have an open invitation.
I've never heard of the guy, but you
have an open invitation to the come on
the show.
>> People always ask me, they he does
history, I believe, and people always
send me his stuff and they're like,
"What is he talking about?"
>> Okay. He has an open invitation to come
on the show to have a conversation.
>> Well, let's see if he comes on. Um,
okay. So the situation in UK, you know,
when we write about this or I hear Matt
Goodwin or Kaufman or someone write
about this, the retort is, well, Muslims
are only 6% of the population.
>> What you you've already you what?
>> No, I mean I I understand they're
they're saying, "Oh, they're only 6%."
Well, that mean that's already a lot.
You know,
>> what other country has a uh a minority
that's 6% that's causing problems? And
the response is, well, they're only 6%.
Let's get 10 and then see how it is. I
mean, yeah, if it's if it's only and I
think it's more than 6%, but if it's
only 6% and you got native pe the native
Brits are losing their mind, then what
the solution is to say it's only six.
Let's get more and see how that happens.
Maybe it'll be better. I'm just laughing
at at at their their twisted logic.
>> So,
okay, there's so much. So, so
historically, you're saying
What are you saying? Like what is the
historical lens?
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. So the historical
thing is this. We can even look at the
UK. All right. The UK. Okay. The
Crusades. What were the Crusades? The
Crusades were a response to Muslims
attacking and killing fellow Christians
in the east in the Holy Land and
desecrating holy sites, right? The holy
all the holy churches and suppleure
supplicer etc. which for early
Christians was was a big deal, right?
Holy holy places. Um so that's what it
was about, right? And it went on century
after century. And the amount of blood
and treasure that the Europeans and
Christians spent is astronomical. I
mean, this is what I do in my books.
This is what I talk about all the time.
And most people are just bewildered. The
people tell me, "I got a degree in
history. I never heard of any of this
stuff." You know, well, yeah, there's a
reason. Um,
>> and the reason is what? Ideological
capture.
>> Yeah. The reason is they don't want you
because we're you Europeans and
Americans are being primed to give in to
their historic enemy. So, we're not
going to tell you that they're your
historic enemy. priming them.
>> Well, that's the question, right? Um, is
it is it a
>> Oh my god. If I ever mentioned that in
one of my classes, I would be hauled
before the diversity board. I mean, I
would not No, like if I ever mentioned
like I mean, it's not in my area, but
>> anything that was even
>> You mean what I was saying?
>> Yeah. I mean, if I ever did that, it
would be
>> But it doesn't matter if it's true.
>> But okay. And that's the problem right
there. That's the problem. Uh because
when people find out the truth, okay, so
going back to, you know, crusades and
holy wars, the enemy was the Muslim,
right? And the Muslim hated, you know,
the Christian, you can't say European
because they just saw each other through
religious lens at that point. Okay? So
all of that has been expuned and people
have been taught in Europe that, you
know what, Muslims were great, you were
evil, crusades are horrible.
>> It's a reverse crusade.
>> It's a reverse crusade. Now it's
incumbent on you to make up for what
your ancestors did by taking them in. I
often hear like you know uh you know the
because of you know the British uh
colonial era and expansion and the idea
is oh because of the horrors we did now
we're letting them come in it's payback
and it's a lot of perverse kind of
thinking it's like guilt tripping it's
kind of guilt tripping and it's kind of
reached the point where I think people
are just like it's not working
>> okay so okay so we have 6% of the
population just going with the UK this
is I I think that's right I don't really
know but roughly
>> I mean those people are losing their
mind in the UK Yeah, you see that little
girl running around with a hatchet and a
sword and
>> I have no idea what that was in response
to.
>> Well, but you know, it's a whatever it
is, it's in response to it's extreme.
And in other words, I don't think it
would have happened 10 years ago. So,
whatever it is or it's uh it just shows
you that we're it's they're reaching
ahead at that point. What? And whoever's
at fault, I'm not even saying.
>> Oh, you mean the the very fact that they
think it's an illegal immigrant or an
immigrant? Yeah, I guess the context is
I don't I don't even know the context,
but I think the fact that they're not
telling us the context is itself
curious.
>> Okay, so let's so let's get back to
that. So there there's a small percent
well under 10.
>> We know that only 10% of those people at
a conservative estimate are causing
problems,
>> right?
>> That doesn't seem like too much of a
problem. Or am I missing something?
Let's keep walking over here.
>> That doesn't seem like too much of a
problem. But the question is, why should
anyone why should a society put up with
this? I mean, imagine I always say this,
you know, if you want to know how bad it
is, always look at it. Let's let's say
if the shoe was on the other foot, look
at another country.
>> And would you blame, let's say, if I
don't know, Saudi Arabia decided to
allow Americans in, right? Yeah. and 6%
of Americans uh were there and all of a
sudden Americans are running havoc and
creating problems and raping and burning
and looting and whatever chopping
cutting people's throats in the street.
>> If I'm trying to answer your question,
but then let's say
>> if 6% if you let in 6% of Americans
>> and 10% of those people were causing or
Vietnamese might be better,
>> whatever.
>> Yeah.
>> And then and then the Saudis said, "You
know what? We think we don't want these
people here anymore." Who in their right
mind, including Americans, would say,
"Oh, that's not fair." Everyone would
say, "Of course." Why would you want to
bring in someone who you're the good
guy? I'm the host. I'm bringing you in.
You should, if anything, reciprocate and
be nice and, you know, grateful, not
trying to kill us, right? No other
country would do this.
>> Yeah. I guess the difference
>> and no one would feel guilty about it.
>> I guess the difference is that they're
not here. Let's go sit over here. I
guess the difference is that they're not
dark.
>> Well, okay. And that shouldn't be a
factor. We shouldn't be that's if you
think that way then you are a racist.
See I don't think that way. I don't care
what their color is. If you behave
certain way then you need to go. But if
we start saying oh color is a factor
then you think and I'm not saying you
but you then we're thinking along racial
terms now.
And we shouldn't do that. Everyone
should be held accountable like an
adult.
What you think?
>> Well I I don't think it's possible for
many people to not think racially. I
think that their their consciousness and
their cognitions have been
>> No, no, it's okay to think racially.
It's okay to, you know, I I've always
hated when someone says, "I'm color
blind." Well, I'm not. When is being
color blind a good thing? It's always Is
it ever better to see black and white
and not see full color? So, um, it's
okay to acknowledge different races, but
what I'm saying is, um, your point is I
was giving you the Saudi Arabia thing
and and the point is, um, oh, if it's
Americans or whoever doing something and
Saudis kick him out, no one would
complain because they're white. But so,
what the idea is that if you're not
white, you should have to get a free
pass to be a criminal. I mean, everyone
should be held to the same standard.
That's not racist, I don't think. But
you're right that people that is the
sort of subconscious understanding that
sort of um you know permeates the masses
intentionally to make them sitting ducks
and to make them in other words all this
stuff that gets thrown on western
nations and how they have to accept it
like you have to suppress your culture
your heritage your religion what other
country does that for for to host some
other people who does that nobody why is
it always the west that has to do it and
and I and I've mentioned this before and
who are the west oh it's the smallest
demographic in the world. You know,
white people are, I don't know, you I
see different numbers, but anywhere from
like 6 to 8, 9% of the world, and
they're the ones that have to give their
land up. They have to accommodate
everyone. They have to suppress their
religion, their identity, they have to
shut their mouth, or they go to jail.
Like, what what how is this fair?
>> I'm going to push back on you, but if
they're too stupid to see what's
happening, maybe they deserve it.
>> Yeah, we've had this and I agree they do
deserve it, but I think a lot of them
are seeing through it. And I think the
ultimate lesson now that I think any
people I hope they are understanding and
let's go back to the UK. I'll give you
an example. A lot of people I once wrote
an article because someone they were
saying Muslims are invading the UK and I
wrote saying no they're not they're not
invading the UK. They're being welcomed
in and there's a big difference. Okay.
Historically Muslims did try to invade
Europe and the Europeans fought back
>> largely repelled.
>> They were repelled largely and if they
weren't then the Europeans were
slaughtered and enslaved and sometimes
for centuries that would happen. But
they were they at least they fought
back. Now you can't say they're invading
because they are being welcomed in and
given everything hotels and food etc. So
what does that tell you? The problem to
me is not the Muslims. It's your leaders
the people who are in position
>> right? So and that's why people need to
get over it. It's I always use this
analogy. You know you put a if I take if
there's a den full of uh zebras and I
introduce a lion and the lion starts
killing zebras. Who's at fault? The lion
or me for letting him in. You know
obviously it's me. The lion's a lion.
He's doing what he's doing. The Muslim's
a Muslim. He's he he has, you know, he
despises the infidel and he, you know,
means means no well for him. Whatever,
right? Attacks him.
>> So, who's at fault? It's their leaders.
>> Yeah. It's interesting. Every
interaction I've had with Muslims has
been positive.
>> I Muslims, see, and this is the problem.
This is actually a good topic now. Um,
the Muslims because they're kind of like
a little more primordial. Western man
his problem is he's so corrupt and
emasculated and he feminized and just
you know doesn't has lost his mooring
with being a man whereas Islam the only
decent thing about it is has this it's
very you know try getting away with this
gender nonsense in a Muslim country you
know give me a break or this trans stuff
no way and I respect that that they do
that they don't tolerate that sort of
thing so yeah and that's kind of the
appeal of the Muslim is that you know on
the one hand he's not he doesn't put up
and and it's also a reflection of the
western man. Just as the western man
puts up with the Muslims nonsense, so
the western man puts up with all kinds
of stupidity in the name of tolerance,
etc., etc., which is why he's getting
trampled upon so easily.
>> There is a kind of glorification of the
weakness of men in western society.
>> Yeah. And but I think that's intentional
because they've taught men that if you
want to be attractive, you have to be
weak. But that's so we can walk all over
you and control you. Who's who are the
arbittors of any society? It's the men.
If you want to control a society, if I'm
this evil, you know, evil Dr. Genius,
whatever, Dr. Evil, and I want to
control a society, the first the number
one thing I'd want to do is to
emasculate the men and to convince the
men that, hey, maybe acting like a woman
is kind of cool. All right? Because uh
that right there is the easiest way to
control and and and then and try to
empower the women and trade just to
create chaos so that nothing even makes
sense and no and everyone's demoralized
and women and men don't get along and
families fall apart. Okay. So that's why
I think even with this whole like trans
and sex gender confusion, it's all by
design. I believe a lot of this is by
design.
>> See, it has to be.
>> I don't I'm not buying that
>> because it's gone. So it's so I used to
think all this is organic. Okay. It's
kind of like a natural development.
>> Who's that? That that assumes philosophy
gone wrong. There's somebody behind it.
>> Yeah. There's
>> like a cabal of Illuminati or somebody
pulling strings. Everyone's a marin
marionette like that. I'm just not I'm
just not
>> You don't believe in conspiracy
theories?
>> See, the problem a lot of people tell me
I don't believe in conspiracy theories.
And I'm not talking about any specific
conspiracy theory. But when you say I
don't believe in a conspiracy theory,
and that's a popular thing to say if you
want to sound rational. What you're also
saying by default is that I believe
everything is transparent and being
shown to me.
>> Because if you and who can believe that?
You'd have to be a fool to believe that.
But if everything isn't transparent and
there's two or more people working
together behind the scenes, which
obviously makes much sense, whether
they're political figures or not, that's
a conspiracy.
>> So I guess if you mean what if you mean
by conspiracy,
I'm fairly confident that the genesis of
this madness is from the university that
>> Yeah. Oh. Oh. Well, that's a that's a
powerful, you know, tool
>> that that groups of deranged people get
together and they fabricate bodies of
literature. the idea have written about
that
>> and Hollywood you know the okay the
>> but Hollywood is downstream of academia
>> no I know
>> because the people get out of academia
and go into Hollywood
>> yeah or you can see them as you know
they're they're kind of the two arms of
the same kind of body one is geared
towards uh stupifying academics and
intellectuals who want to be smart and
one is for the masses Hollywood but they
both have the same message right and I
I'll give you another example on this
topic that we're talking about and to
show you like uh so if You look at
history and you look today, every
culture, every civilization, they
venerate their forefathers and their
ancestors, right? I mean, this is like a
it's across the board and no one would
argue or complain and say you're bad for
doing that. Even if their ancestors are
bad, it's a natural instinct. It makes
sense. You know, we it's part of our
continuity, our bloodline, our heritage,
etc. And, you know, and I see this a lot
with the Muslim world and and the kind
of Muslims that they venerate are pretty
nasty people. I mean, we're talking
about mass slavers, uh, you know, like
someone like Mahmed or Muhammad II, the
Ottoman Sultan who, let's just take my
word for I don't want to waste time on
it, but I write about him a lot. The
stuff he did is pretty despicable and
abominable, but he's got statues
everywhere in Turkey. Okay. Now, you
come to the west where they actually
have really good ancestors they should
celebrate and they're hated and there so
much disdain and you know, George
Washington statue, Abraham Lincoln,
whatever have to go down Churchill.
Okay,
>> Lincoln in in in uh Portland, they
ripped down the statue of Lincoln.
>> Said he's a Nazi. There's a SWAT sticker
with a line through it there.
>> But here's the thing, you know what?
Let's forget what they really are, what
they weren't. My point is people don't
do that to their ancestors even when
they know they're bad because it's part
of our it's our it's our team and we're
we got our guy. He's our guy. Okay.
>> But we do that to our ancestors. We love
doing that to our ancestors.
>> And the question is why? Because but
there's an important reason when you
tear down your ancestors and your
history. Yeah.
>> Okay. You've just you've renounced your
leg your heritage. You've said no to it.
>> But they want to renounce. They want to
they think that the system itself is the
cause that needs to be dismantled and
disrupted.
>> Right. But a lot of this
>> and that's being taught in the
university.
>> Exactly. And that's the fake history
that I'm always combating because fake
history makes people hate their
ancestors and it was intentional to make
you so they lie about the past.
>> And the way that they try to
make it so that everything you you're
writing about and speaking about doesn't
have to be taken seriously is they call
you far right.
>> Right. Yeah. Yeah. Or or everything, you
know, let's say slavery. You know, you
mentioned slavery on campus. Oh,
everyone knows about slavery. They know
about the transatlantic slavery. That's
it. And the idea is only white people
ever engaged in slavery.
>> Did Muslims tell us a little bit about
Muslims?
>> Yeah, much more than whites ever did.
And they enslaved tons of whites. In the
16th century alone, there was 1.2
million whites in Barbrey, North Africa,
who were kidnapped by Muslims, and they
were all taken from Europe. As far as
Iceland, they would go and Denmark.
>> Many on the left would argue that's a
good thing.
So it's bad when whites enslave blacks,
but when blacks enslave whites, that's a
good thing.
>> It's a kind of egalitarianism of
slavery. Like you, it's not so so that
whites took a lot of I'm not saying I
believe that.
>> No, I know you said a lot of people say
that.
>> So So it it it's it's not that uh so so
whites took a lot of blacks and it's
only fair that other non people should
take white people as slaves. I see if
Yeah, that equals everything out. So
What I'm saying is they did it first.
The Muslims and the Africans were
actually enslaving whites before the
transatlantic slave trade.
>> So then they would have to make the
argument that
>> it was still good obviously because it
was it was multiculturalism, you know,
but
>> so okay. So when you present people with
this argument that there were actually
Muslim slave traders and a lot of them
who took a a significant number of white
people. What what is the response? Is it
they deserved it? Is it, you know,
denialism? No, that's not true.
>> Is it What is the response?
>> In my experience, the response, and I'm
the one who's really been doing this,
uncovering lots in the in the historical
field, the best response for them is
nothing. just act like they never heard
it and never never um you know they
won't debate me. They won't read that's
why if you can get that guy or anyone
I'm more than happy to.
>> So you're willing to debate that what
whatever that dude's name is. I don't
know his name. So you're willing to come
on and debate the guy?
>> Absolutely.
>> Okay. Tell you what's going to happen.
>> What's going to happen?
>> They're going to say I didn't reach out
to him.
>> They're going to say well yeah but
they're going to say you know he he sent
us emails but the emails were never
responded to. I can already tell you
that. That's happened to me before with
other people. I know. I know. I know the
>> You didn't really send them. You didn't
really mean
>> because how do you win? Here's the
thing. When we come to facts in history,
you know, and if you're smart, if if I
was in that guy's position going against
me and I see what I'm saying, what am I
going to say? I mean, the facts the the
record is the record. So, that's why
their strongest um apologetic or defense
or damage control is is denial and
ignoring it. And don't even look at it.
Don't talk to him. Suppress him. when I
was invited to give a talk at the war
college, the US Army War College about
about history care the the Council on
American Islamic Relations and all these
leftist groups flipped out and called me
a racist and a white supremacist and but
they couldn't say it was about my book
sword and simar white supremacist.
>> Yeah, me but they couldn't find anything
wrong in my book. They didn't say, "Oh,
on page so and so, he lied." It's funny
how the semantic range of that term has
>> Yeah. Egyptian guys become a white
supremacist
>> continuously from you know Scandinavians
or Germans.
>> Yeah. Because these words are just made
to shut you down. That's it. And that's
why another thing I would say you know
it's sad because you know things like uh
racism do exist right but these words
are being so overplayed and being
weaponized and it's you know the only
way around it is I think people need to
just not care. Sticks and stones may
break my bones or words. You know, you
should people should take an attitude
where you know what, if you want to call
me racist, call me a racist. You want to
call me anything, call me anything.
>> So, here's here's I'm above and beyond.
>> Here's a problem problem with that. So,
we're going to do an event tomorrow at
Comedy Solar.
>> You don't disclose your whereabouts
because some lunatic could saw your head
off
>> and yet we've posted your name and face
to like I don't even know how many
people at this point, right? Right.
>> And so now we have to be concerned about
getting security so that no one murders
you or blows themselves up in the middle
of the comedy solo,
>> right?
>> And what does that tell us about the
current situation now when you go back
to the small minority and say, "Oh, in
America, I think Muslims are 1%." And we
have situations like that. So, uh, you
know,
>> I think that was the book the the case
with the Book of Mormon when no, you
know, what did Mormons do? they took out
an ad if but no nobody is worrying about
Mormons killing anybody else
>> right
>> but again I guess the retort I can hear
the retort now is that this is such a
small number of people who are radical
and there's a small number of any
religion who's radical
okay this is like this this is like
someone telling me hey I'm going to give
you a a jar full of candy there's like a
hundred little pieces of candy and only
two are poison only three are going to
kill you what's the big deal. Just let's
all eat from it. What if I say I don't
want to take the chance? I'd rather not
have all those sweets that and but also
not die.
>> Yeah, but in the case of the UK and then
I'm going to ask you a question about
Palestinians.
>> What is what do they get? What what does
the UK get in the
>> in return for what they taken?
>> What?
>> Well, I mean you're you're asking
>> exoticis
guy. I mean,
>> I'm trying to think what there should be
a reciprocal. Okay, I understand what
migrants are getting.
>> I don't know. Replacing the population.
uh some kind of economic advant although
that's not true when you look at the the
data for incarceration rates and for who
contributes to the treasury but so is it
true that if you looked at a population
like Palestinians
same culture same history same language
same tradition same everything but it
and again this is outside my area but
there are not many if any Christian
suicide bombers but there are Muslim
suicide bombers so that
>> you can point to the one very When you
quote unquote science something, you
want to keep all of the variables the
same and change only one of the
variables.
>> Exactly. And what what is it? It's
Islam. And but you can't say that. I
understand that people don't want to say
that. But just like you pointed out,
there's a lot of why where's the
Palestinian Christian suicide bomber?
Well, because it's just not part of
their thing. It's part of
>> the way the way that people respond to
that is they don't talk to you and call
you far right because they can't respond
to it with reason, evidence, and
argument or they would be coming on the
show and talking. And the reason that we
would want them to come on the show is
like you don't really want them.
Actually, I do. You against one of these
guys would get a crazy number of views.
So, actually, it is in my own interest.
>> Bring it on. I'd love it. Anybody?
>> Yeah. They won't come. They won't come.
I know. But okay. So, are you optimistic
about the future of Western Europe?
>> Um, I think Western Europe is it's going
to get worse and worse until it can
possibly get better. It's going to get
primitive, I think, because what what
what the Europeans need to understand
is, okay, and I know your point about
conspiracy and cabal and all that, but
what they have to understand is the real
enemy is the people ruling them, their
own leaders. Okay? And what now, why
they're doing all that, I don't know. I
can't get into that. But that's the
source of why this is happening. So,
it's it seems like they need to get rid
of them. I think most of the people
>> like vote reform in England.
>> I mean whatever we say vote and it's
kind of like that's what they've been
doing and either the voting is rigged or
the people once they vote them in they
all of a sudden all do the same thing.
>> And it's kind of like
>> well if they all did the same thing
they'd have to be some reason for it
>> something behind it. Right. And uh and
here's another here's
>> especially if they said they wouldn't do
the same thing. Yeah. What's your other
thought?
>> Here's the other thought is like you
know we're all conditioned especially in
the west war is bad. Never engage in
war. And we all have freedom of speech.
We have freedom of expression. War is
horrible. I get it.
>> But you know when when is war justified
and uh in other words
>> just war theory. There are definitely
just like in someone arguing in the case
of genocide. But go ahead.
>> Let's say okay let's say this UK
situation, right? Let's say no matter
what the the government is going to keep
bringing in more and more migrants and
Muslims and is going to keep is going to
clamp down on suppressing the native
Europeans as putting them in jail, you
know, for speaking their mind.
>> Yeah. All of that. Okay. And it just and
no matter what they do, it just gets
worse and worse. Year goes by and
there's more attacks, more violence on
little kids. Okay. At what point does
war actually become plausible and fair
and logical?
>> Probably never. I
>> But what if that's what if that's their
only option?
>> Yeah, but they did it to themselves.
>> Okay.
>> Like if they didn't do it to
>> So it's okay that they let themselves
die, but they can't fight back now.
Well, I mean, if you told me that
they're coming, that they're invading,
then you
>> No, I'm not saying war against Muslims.
I'm saying war against their leaders.
That's what I mean. That's the source.
>> Oh, like an uprising against their
leaders.
>> Yeah. Not the Muslims. That the Muslims,
that's a byproduct. That's a side effect
is the Islam thing. It's not inherent.
Islam is weak. Look at countries like
Hungary and Poland. They don't have this
problem, right?
>> They don't have the problem at all.
>> They just don't let it in. Okay, we're
done. No problem. We put up a little
fence and we're done. So the the issue
is just their leaders and um
>> so at what point does a kind of mutiny
or civil war against your leader is it
morally justified
>> Yeah.
>> because they're not listening to the
interest of the people. I would say
that's a good question.
>> Isn't that isn't that the American
Revolution?
>> Well, my gut tells me never since you
vote if if the elections were fair.
>> Right. Right. But what if Okay. What if
they're fair and whoever once you know
you see this all the time a leader or a
person politician gets elected and he
said all the perfect things but once he
gets in power and people are saying
Trump Trump is doing this I've heard
arguments against Trump he he be he he
becomes like the rest and he starts you
know in other words if it's just a
corrupt system and there's no beating it
no matter what. Okay. At what point do
the people, if you're constantly year
after year, decade after decade,
watching yourself being degraded and
weakened and and primed for a takeover
by invaders? When do you finally, you
know, grow the cojones and say, "Uh, I'm
done with this and I know my leaders are
not well, for whatever reason, they're
not helping me. Now I have to be a man
and do something about it."
>> I don't know. I'm I'm
>> And I know that's not an easy question.
It's, you know,
>> I mean, I don't know in
>> Nor am I inciting anything. I'm just
trying. It's a philosophical
observation.
>> Yeah. No, no. I'm thinking of of
Socrates and the apology
>> when he says, you know, I live by the
laws, the rules of the state. I'm not
going to escape.
>> Right.
>> Uh I I I don't I my gut is to say it's
not ever justified. But I guess if it
were true cultural suicide and that if
you didn't do anything, the whole
culture would vanish. then it gets back
to what I said a few be before that
would show an inherent flaw of the
system and maybe it should vanish
>> right that's what I'm saying I mean the
current system in these European
countries obviously doesn't have the
people's interest at heart I saw a video
of uh I think it was in Munich it was in
Germany it was some cong or
parliamentarian woman with short hair I
forget her name but uh she gets up and
she's like yeah I want to tell all you
right-wingers that in 10 years the
Germans are going to be a minority in
this city and that's a good thing.
>> What kind of mentality is that? That is
I mean it this is the sad part. They've
conditioned people to act and think this
is good and it's suicidal.
>> All right, let's talk about that. So
what is her?
>> So God, it just kills me that the can't
these people will not talk cuz I'd love
to know the reason behind that.
>> You want to invite you want to interview
them and they no they're not going to
come. But what is the reason that she
thinks that it's a good thing that there
are going to be no Germans in Germany?
Well, she I would think she's a perfect
product of the indoctrination that
Western Europe, especially German, has
gone through, which is it's it's just
about self-loathing. It's all about I,
me, and my heritage, us evil white
races,
>> phobia, the hate, West selfhatred,
>> and we need to do everything possible to
help uh the the brown people.
>> But even if that's the case, why would
you want no more Germans living in
Germany or no more?
>> Because it's a celebration living in
Vietnam.
>> Well, that's the thing I told you. If
you think about it in any other context,
it sounds crazy. Who would say, imagine
some Cuban saying, "We I want
>> we don't want any Cubans living in
Cuba."
>> Well, it doesn't make sense. But they've
gotten Western people to think it's my
duty as a good uh noble western person
who who acknowledges the crimes of my
ancestors to become a doormat and let
everyone in and I have to shut my mouth
and be and suppress myself
>> because there's something inherently
evil in the nature of whiteness. And
>> they got them believing that.
>> They got them believing that. And then
if we can just
>> which is why there's a war on history
people there's a war history there has
to be a war in history
>> that that's why there's a war on history
making teaching them the fake history
okay because that's the if if whites are
evil well that means we have to look at
the history and then the history is all
lies and it's all distorted and you
don't know that actually the whites were
always oftentimes the victims and the
ones who were being killed and enslaved
and they were the ones fighting back for
their in the name of you know and even
you know in one of my books I I do a
close look at what happened to which
book
>> the new one actually two swords of
Christ which deals with the Templars and
the hospitalist.
>> Are you a Christian?
>> I am Orthodox.
>> Okay.
>> Um which means if you ask other
Christians, they'll say I'm not a
Christian. But anyway, um in in that
book,
>> well, if a guy can identify as a woman,
you can certainly identify as a
Christian.
>> Yeah, I hope so.
But uh um in that book uh the I talk
about slavery a little bit and you see
uh you know the Christians especially
the knights would enslave Muslims as a
tit for tat because of what was
happening but it was like 3% of what the
amount that Muslims enslaved the
Christians but if you look at how they
were treated so the Muslims in Malta for
example the knights of of Malta
>> um they could they could have a mosque
they had their prayer leader etc. In
North Africa, when you talk about the
the white slaves under Islam, first of
all, they were all like raped by, you
know, and sodomized. And if they say or
do anything, the the tortures that they
would go through throw, you know,
cutting their nose and eyes out and
throwing them to hang on a hook.
>> This is all historically document.
>> Oh, yeah. All historically documented.
So, you know, even in this in that
sense, you see the difference in how the
different groups treated each other. My
point is history has been so weaponized.
is I call it fake history because the
only way to get white people to believe
all the evil stuff about their ancestors
is to lie about history.
>> You have to let them know that only
white people did bad things,
>> right?
>> That's the idea.
>> White people did bad things to everybody
else and ever did anything bad.
>> And now you have to make up for it.
>> Isn't that it's a kind of experiential
reparations,
>> I guess. Yeah. Even though even even if
it was true, why should any white person
today do anything or even a black person
because none of them suffered. the white
person today is not the enslaver and the
black person today has never been
enslaved. So even if it was true, I
don't even get it. It doesn't make sense
because that it implies that we have to
be, you know, we're responsible for the
crimes of our ancestors. What kind of
society is that? Um but the point is
it's not even true in the sense that
it's so pulled out of context and you
don't get the full picture. And you
know, I've seen this woman Bridget
Cooper and she's a professor at
>> Oh, you know, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. and not
of her
>> and she goes and she's a professor and
she says stuff like white people are
inherently evil. They're committed to
being evil and this is she is a perfect
product of what I'm talking about.
>> So I guess my concern is every time I
have these kinds of conversations. I had
one with Ralph Scholeamemer. I'm always
concerned that people are going to watch
this and be like,
>> "Well, these are two like white dudes.
They're like white."
>> Okay. Well, I'm actually barely white if
I'm white. I don't know. Is there
Armenians or white? I don't even know
any.
>> Yeah. Uh but it but it's I don't I don't
really know. I It's just such a potent
mind virus.
>> Exactly.
>> That you
>> that they've gotten people that you deny
history. You deny
>> and they cement the narrative by not
having people come on
>> right
>> from the other side to have the
conversation about. So there's really
nothing you can do about it. There's
just there's just it's like a battle of
competing narratives and there's no
middle. There's just like a cudgel which
is in a way it's it's a very postmodern
position. It all comes down to power.
It's all about who wields the power and
and effectively wields the power.
>> So, and they'll do whatever to to not be
threatened. Whether it's to suppress
you, whether it's to call you a racist,
or whether it's just ignore you and
pretend you don't exist. I mean, look at
all these guys who used to be on
YouTube. Now they're like kicked out on
Rumble.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah.
>> Because they said the wrong thing,
right?
>> Yeah. I noticed on Twitter you follow
Yasmin Muhammad.
>> Yeah, that's only because I'm actually
now starting to follow people. Yeah, she
interviewed me recently.
>> Yasmin is fantastic. Her book Unveiled
was was absolutely absolutely wonderful
and I've done a few things with her. We
did uh Spectrum Street Epistemology with
her. I did we did a few things and what
one of the things she said was about
have having a Muslim as a close friend
orthodox or I can't remember the word
orthodox or strict Muslim
>> and she said that they want to kill her.
>> Kill her.
>> Yeah. Because apostate. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So I was wondering if you could
talk about that because every time I
mention that people say it's not true.
>> They don't really want to kill
apostates. It's not really illegal in 11
countries. is they don't it's like so I
want
>> all right so well there's a lot to
unpack there so according to Islamic law
Sharia it is it's it's forbidden it's
illegal and there is a punishment for it
>> there's that in the Quran
>> it's derived from the Quran but it's
mostly the hadith there's a canonical
hadith where Muhammad says he who leaves
his religion kill him okay so based on
that you you have four primary orthodox
small O schools of jurist prudence in
Islam Sunni Islam and each of them will
treat it as a horrible thing some will
say kill. Some will say if it's a woman,
you just beat her up and put her in a
room for a year, starve her. So, it's
horrific treatment up to death. Not
necessarily has to be death, but it
waivers. Um, and then countries, now
countries, what they do is a lot of
these Muslim countries because they know
how bad it is to codify this in their
actual laws, they don't, but they still
act on it. You know what I And so it's
like a it's like if you become an
apostate in a Muslim country, there's no
law necessarily that will say you're to
be killed, but they'll leave you to the
to the angry mob and they'll look the
other way while the angry mob tears you
to pieces or your family often. Um so so
long and short of it is I would not want
to be a Muslim who openly apostasizes
living in an Islamic country. I would
not feel safe.
So Brussels is having Brussels is doing
something like the Kuran project for
like what is it 10 million euros or
something?
>> Yeah. Yeah. This actually is perfect. Uh
it really applies to what we've been
talking about. It just shows it's again
Okay. So Brussels the EU have are
sponsoring a project. It's actually been
going on for years. It's called the
Quran.
>> Okay.
>> And they're spending about 10 million
euros which is a lot. And it's dedicated
to showing you how Islam has been
misunderstood and has always belonged in
the continent of Europe.
>> Interesting. Okay.
>> Okay. So, this is what I mean by fake
history. This is a perfect example of,
hey, let's pacify these crazy right-wing
St. George loving uh Europeans.
>> St. George.
>> Yeah. By showing them that, you know
what, you guys are idiots. Muslims have
always been here. And all that, of
course, is complete hogwash, complete
lies. Yeah. They have been in Europe,
but usually to kill and rape and murder
um historically as conquerors of course.
So, and we can get into that, you know,
because I recently actually wrote about
it, but
>> in what book?
>> I actually wrote an article about it. I
did a video about it on YouTube because
this is this is uh recent development.
But when I look also I looked at some of
the people that they're paying all this
money to who are involved, academics
>> and other people the some of them are
connected to the Muslim Brotherhood.
>> Okay.
Tell us tell people a little bit about
what is the Muslim Brotherhood.
>> Okay. The Muslim Brotherhood is seen as
often the oldest Islamic organization
and it was born in Egypt I believe I
want to say 1929 by Hassan Albena an
Egyptian guy and um it's kind of like
the parent organization. A lot of
terrorists actually started off in the
Muslim Brotherhood such as Aean Zwahi
who became the al-Qaeda leader after
Osama was killed and they're very
surreptitious. They try to act like
they're peaceful, but there's a lot of
evidence against, you know, that they
somehow are not necessarily peaceful.
They engage in terrorism, but they put
on this front. So, the organization that
came up against me and was screaming
because I was going to the war college,
CARE, is a byproduct. It's connected to
the Muslim Brotherhood. There was
actually a leaked uh a document that was
captured by the FBI, which names CARE as
an affiliate of the Muslim Brotherhood,
for example. But they're basically uh if
you want to talk about a cabal, they're
a cabal and they're multinational.
They're all over the place and they
exist to do exactly that. Rehabilitate
Islam's image on the one hand and attack
people like me from
>> and then you get the things like the
project that Brussels is putting out,
>> right? And that's exactly so it's they
they work hand inand on the one hand you
have the Muslim side which makes sense.
Okay. Because Islam has always been the
historic enemy. Can I can I throw out a
hypothesis and you tell me if it's full
of full full of beans or not?
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Do you think one of the reasons
that this is happening is that people
realize that there's a critical mass now
>> and they don't want to risk inflaming
people for a kind of uprising. Civil war
might be way too strong, but
>> Right. Right.
>> They they want to It really is about
safety when you raise the St. George
flag. I would say it really is. Yeah. I
would say that might be somewhat legit
and it's a plausible kind of approach.
But if you're doing that, then okay,
then I hope that also means you admit
that you're the fault that you played in
making it get to this point and now
you're going to do something hopefully
quietly behind the scenes to fix it,
which would include actually getting
getting rid of the the migrants. But
that's not what's happening. It seems
like it's the opposite. In other words,
I get it if they're like, "Okay, hey, we
don't want civil war, so let's do what
we got to do. But now let's fix what we
did." Well, let's fix what's causing the
anger. But they're not doing that.
They're they're doubling down. They're
bringing in more migrants and uh and
they're and they're forcing the people
to shut up and take it.
>> Okay. What would a far-right position on
immigration be?
>> Well, that's the funny thing. See, when
when people say a far-right position, to
me, a far the the most far-right radical
position is what your average sane
non-western person would do in their own
country. Okay? which would be I don't
want outsiders here because the way they
act they're not Japanese.
>> Yeah. You're not assimilating. This is
my country. You have your country and
that's the end of it. This is but that's
far right.
>> But yet they would not call those people
>> Exactly. Because it's a weaponized word
for whites and Europeans.
>> So only in a western context is going to
limit immigration considered far right.
When a western man acts like a normal
man, he's far right. That's the whole
point. Like when a western person does
what uh
when western people do what non-western
people do all the time and which is
taken for granted and which is
considered common sense and
self-preservation and self-respect. When
they do that, they get tred as evil
racists and right-wing lunatics, right?
Because like you said, they'll never use
those terms for like you said the
Japanese, right? Okay. It's their
country. That's they want it that way.
>> Yeah. I just read complain. I just read
the stats on on how many refugees the
Japanese take and
>> I I can't remember what is it like
something like below 100 I think 79. But
okay. So anyway, that's interesting. So
>> why is that though? Why is it always
just the white countries that have to
that if they that if they think the way
other people think they become horrible
right now? Just hatred the west hatred.
>> Yeah,
>> exactly. And is that is that organic or
is it something else? Because it's
because if it's organic, why doesn't it
happen in other places?
>> Okay. So, we talked about the concept of
a farright position. What's a far-left
position on immigration? Well, I a
far-left position, I imagine, would be
Yeah. would be, you know, I've I've I've
drank all the Kool-Aid they've given me,
>> and I believe my societyy's evil, and
it's my duty as a good person to make it
up to all the the brown people who are
not my people, and I have to do anything
that makes them happy. I give them
everything off my shirt, and I have to
make my hair blue and green, too,
because that's part of my stupidity. And
uh you know that's that's the far-left
position, right?
>> Uh so bringing it back to the United
States, the United States has nowhere
near the kinds of problems with
immigrant want to say immigration cuz
people are freaking out about I actually
love with Islam.
>> I actually love Mexican immigration. I
think Muslim I know that that's that I
would get 5,000 people like oh
>> no but you see there's something winger.
like, you know,
>> but there's something in what you said
where, you know, I prefer it too because
whatever, you know, okay, all illegal
immigration is illegal immigration, but
at least, you know, with Mexican
immigration,
>> it's not going to have that anti-infidel
violence and, you know, it's not going
to have that.
>> I again, I just, you know, when Trump
the first term was screaming about
Mexicans being murders and rapist,
that's just not borne out by the data.
But but bracket that for a second. Okay.
So
>> so so we don't have the same kinds of
problems in the west with Muslim
immigration that we do that that we in
the United States, excuse me, that
>> and so talk me through that because my h
speculation was that we take in a
different kind of immigrant,
>> right? Yeah. Well, if you're talking
about it, the thing with Europe is due
to its proximity to the Islamic world,
almost all the migrants that come are
Muslim. They're from the Muslim world,
the vast majority because what's south
of Europe? Islam. What's southeast of
Europe? Uh, you know, after Russia,
Islam. Okay. Uh, Central Asian
countries. So, it's so surrounded that
whenever it gets migrants, they tend to
be Muslim. Uh, in the US, it's different
as you noted. And, um, it brings its own
issues. But again, you know, even the
the migrant issue in America, let's put
the Islam thing aside. It still makes
sense. You know, you have people in
America who are starting to feel like
we're becoming the minority. We're
giving we have to we're fleeing
California. We're fleeing the big
cities. Why should it be like that? What
other country does that to itself where,
you know, it allows its big cities all
to become crimeridden and ghettoized and
>> Yeah. I just I just read today that my
city where I lived for such a long time,
Portland, is the number two most
dangerous
>> city in the country.
>> And it's also one of the most liberal.
>> Yeah, go figure.
>> So, give me a reality check. I was happy
about that.
>> Why? Because there has to be a
connection between
in a democracy or only in a democracy
between the people you vote for and the
policies they enact and you have to to
step up and take responsibility for what
it is that you've done.
>> Mhm.
>> Cuz if you don't have some kind of
accountability through democratic action
and processes, then what are you doing?
You're so the way to make people
responsible. It's like Charles Murray's
What It Means to be a libertarian. It's
kind of the same principle of that book.
It's like the way to make people
responsible. God, I'm smelling pot
constantly. There's like almost nobody
around here.
>> Go ahead. Continue with the Portland
thing.
>> Yeah. But the the way to make people
responsible is there has to be some kind
of accountability. Some people need to
know that there's a direct connection
between the people they vote in, the
policies they enact, the lives they
lead. You're happy because when Portland
suffers, the people get to see that this
is your you're doing
>> because of who you voted for.
>> Yeah.
>> But the problem is that they will never
do that. The problem is
>> they'll they'll double down and they'll
need more leftism.
>> No, they'll blame the far right. There's
some like cabal of like Proud Boys or
like some secret,
>> you know, thing, you know, so
>> they can't take responsibility.
>> It's fascinating to me why policies at
all. And maybe we'll differ on this, but
why is there like a right-wing or a
left-wing policy as opposed to an
evidence policy? So, for example, like
when data is not right or left, like
global climate data is not right or
left. There's just data. What you do
with the data in terms of your public
policy that is inherently political.
That's I think one of the biggest
problems nowadays is we are trapped in
this left right spectrum.
>> I completely
>> and it's so artificial to I mean there's
parts of it like for example when you
when when when someone comes and starts
saying hey I'm a man but you have to
call me a woman or you go to jail. I'm
sorry this is no longer left. This is
stupidity. This is insanity. But when we
call it left, we give it dignity and we
we give it the the weight of ideology
and then we have to contend with it as
if it's just another part of the
spectrum. Doesn't belong there at all.
And I think uh people need to start I
hate the word the left for this very
reason cuz it allows stupidity and evil
to hide essentially. When you say a man
that wants to, you know, dress up as a
woman and go teach little or or read a
book to little kids, that's not left,
man. That's predatory. That's evil.
That's sick. But but you see the
importance of the words. If I would have
called it that, a lot of people would be
uh you know would kind of get it. But
when you call it the left, it hides. It
blends in. Oh, it's just a different
political view.
>> And it's kind of like we need to get
>> political views are equal. Oh, cool.
Look at the turtles.
>> Yeah,
>> dude. Get the turtles. Get the turtles.
>> Lucky guys.
>> How cool is that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, you don't like And I agree
with you. You don't like the right and
the left characters.
>> It's an artificial dichotomy.
>> It just uh it it Look, I believe there
is a political spectrum. But you know
what? It used to be like when people
talk about I'm a fiscal conservative.
Okay, I get that. But when you talk
about things like morality or questions
about truth,
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. I mean, and then you say, "Oh,
that's leftwing or that's right-wing."
That's that I think that just is an
oversimplification. But it also like I
said it hides crazy perverse thinking
and gives it respectability.
>> Okay. So let let me ask
>> and a lot I would I would argue a lot of
leftists would even agree with me and
say yeah we hate the fact in fact they
have said this to me. We hate the fact
that we get conflated with these loonies
you know the trans people let's say
>> and that they're they've appropriated
our movement or whatever.
>> Yeah. They they've bartered economic
considerations for identity. Yeah.
>> So so let me ask you a question. So we
have a large number of people and maybe
you'll disagree with that but we have a
lot of people let me say say that who
don't think there's any problem with
large numbers of Islamic immigration in
Western Europe.
>> Mhm.
>> And then we have other people who think
it's a problem.
Is is there a what is the solution or
you think it's a problem? Islamic
immigration in Western Europe. What is
or in in the Do you think it's a problem
in the United States as well?
>> The number wise is not nowhere near as
bad as in Europe. I mean, depending on
what you look at, I hear it's sometimes
like only 1%. In America and and a
majority of those, I heard at one point
half of them are African-Americans who
convert in jail, which on the one hand
also kind of means I don't know how
serious they are about their Islam. It's
just some kind of like identity cool
thing they do. Um but yeah that's
wherever you have Islam okay once if it
can grow and breathe and become Islam
true Islam it's going to be a problem
it's just in America is nowhere near as
bad as Europe but it's on that
trajectory obviously
>> so what is the solution in Western
Europe would it be a moratorium on all
immigration would what would
>> I would say yeah I mean you've got
enough
>> right put an end to it right now and
then I mean and the ones who are there
illegally They should probably be sent
right back, right?
>> What if somebody commits a crime
>> and that person too? The point is coming
to another country, you have to be Look,
my parents were immigrants to the United
States.
>> From Egypt.
>> Yeah. From Egypt.
>> They came legally. I remember I wasn't
even born, but you know, my my parents
had to wait years to get their, you
know, whatever to come to the US.
>> Yeah.
>> And when they came in, you know, they're
grateful. It's like we want to we want
to fit in. We want to do the right
thing. We want to be a contribution.
grandparents were immigrants
>> and they you know like they were humble
about it and they want to contribute.
>> So what's the solution now? Tell me the
solution.
>> Well the solution is I mean there's
different ways to look at it. The
philosophical solution which I like to
start with because the basic simple way
the common sensical way is just uh
enough with the I I let's say I'm a
European American or European. It's my
job to hate and renounce everything
about my past and my job to, you know,
do everything possible for everyone
who's not white, including step over
myself and, you know, destroy my culture
and my nationality, my my, you know, my
heritage.
>> Okay, that's the first step. That's the
simple step.
>> And and the way to help people think
about that is they wouldn't want for,
for example, the Japanese to do that or
they wouldn't want the Nigerians to
repudiate,
>> right? Nobody does that. Nobody does
that. And the first step on that road,
believe it or not, and this is why this
is my field, is history. Because
everyone assumes they know every the
people who I'm talking about who think,
you know, their ancestors were monsters,
they think they know history, but
they've been fed a lie. They've been fed
a fake history like this, you know, EU
thing we're talking about.
>> And that history
>> has been from top to bottom has all
about been about demonizing their
ancestors. So, no wonder they hate them
because if you believe that stuff,
they're are monsters. Okay? And and the
consequences of it are things like well
we need to rip down statues.
>> Right. Exactly. Yeah. And just and and
in short be the opposite of how they
were. So they used to fight Muslims from
coming into Europe. So we are going to
take them in. Show you how great and
tolerant we are. Okay. But if you
understand the real history that these
guys were actually fighting to maintain
their lives and their families and
freedom. They weren't aggressors. It was
the Muslims who were the aggressors who
were coming into Europe who took People
forget. Think about it all these
countries from you know all of North
Africa from Morocco to Egypt and all the
Middle East. Yeah.
>> That was which is now the heart of the
Muslim world that was all Christian and
it was conquered violently in the 7th
century
>> and Spain was conquered and they went
all the way up to Tur in the middle of
France and then later the Ottomans
conquered the Balkans and the Tatars who
were Muslims conquered Russia and it was
a free I mean it was a constant it was
it was the it was like the perennial
war. Every European knew it. the enemy
is the Muslim and the Muslim hated the
European. He's our enemy. And then all
of a sudden that that real history
thousands of over a thousand years has
been jettisoned and now all of a sudden
Europeans are the bad guys and the
Muslims are the innocent victims.
>> Okay. What would you say to those
Muslims who say, "Listen, yeah, there is
a lot of crazy shit in our history, but
we're just here, you know, we speak the
language. We just want to make some
money. We just want to be treated
fairly. We're not saring anybody's head
off. We're not blowing shit up. What
would you say to them?
>> I would say I get it. I understand it
and I believe you. As as I already
indicated earlier, I said let's say
let's say 10% are the bad guys. Um
>> but but here's the thing, like why
should the burden of proof, okay, let's
say I get it and they don't want to be
stereotyped, right?
>> Yeah.
>> But the burden I mean the burden of the
proof should why is it put on the
European? In other words, why should the
European say, "Okay, I'm going to give
you all benefit of the doubt because
that's the only way to do And then I get
killed.
>> Well, because they're already in the
country.
>> Yeah.
>> So, it is unfair to the 90% of Muslims.
Again, I'm just going with that figure.
We can we can have that conversation.
But it is unfair to the 90% of Muslims
that 10% of their fellow Muslims are
fucking lunatics who were literally
hellbent on destroying the nature of
society, killing the Jews, etc. Right?
>> But it's it is still unfair to 90%.
>> I get it. And then but there's another
consideration to keep in mind is you
know what as long as you're a Muslim and
I've seen this happen a lot of times
they turn from just being normal to
being a terrorist because because the
doctrine is there in their head and sure
they ignore it for most of their lives
but just a couple of set of
circumstances go wrong and they get
bitter and all of a sudden boom it's
terrorist mode and I've seen this with a
lot of the terrorist attacks in in in
Europe you find that oh he was always
secular oh he never read the Quran and
then like two weeks before the attack
you find out he's started own a mosque,
you know. So, that's not to say, of
course, that uh I'm not trying to say
that all Muslims are going to do that.
I'm just saying it's it is a problem. It
is a sticky situation. I mean, here's a
here's what a Europe and this is what a
medieval European would say.
>> Yeah.
>> He would say, "Okay, well, but we know
your religion is hostile. We need it.
So, you can openly apostasize and
renounce it." That's actually what they
did. So, in Spain, here's a perfect
example. We always hear about the
Inquisition, right? That's another
perfect example of how monstrous
>> Europeans were. And I'm not trying to
rehabilitate the Inquisition, but I'm
giving you context. I'm giving you
context. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> So, the context, here's what you're
told. It it it comes off as just these
Spaniards especially who decided to just
attack peaceful Jews and Muslims and do
this inquisition and force them to
become Christian and if not, they kick
them out. Okay?
>> So, that is all true. Now, here's the
problem. Here's the missing context.
>> Okay? Right? Why was that? Now, the
assumption that they want you to believe
>> is that because they're just crazy crazy
Christians and they're xenophobes and
they just want everyone to be like them
and radicals.
>> No, the truth is as someone who's digged
into this and written about it.
>> The Muslims especially were what they
would do is they would convert. Okay.
First, when when the Spaniards
reconquered most of Spain and took
Granada, they told the Muslims, you can
keep your religion and live according to
your Sharia, no problem. But for decades
they kept subverting and and working
with the barbary pirates and working
with the Ottomans and they were
basically a fifth. So the final so
that's when the crown said look you
either become a Christian or you leave.
The logic was it's not because they want
you to be a Christian but they wanted
you to leave Islam and the only
alternative then of course is to become
a Christian. There's no atheism in you
know the 13th century
>> or whatever the the time is. So
>> or there's no there are no out atheists.
>> Right. Right. Yeah. Yeah. So the logic
is this is how you leave your religion.
So that's what they were trying to do
and and to show you. And so what what
the Muslims did is they got a actual
fatwa to practice tea. Tea is this
doctrine which allows you to lie, right?
So they got they you know this is
Catholic Spain. So they got baptized.
They went to church. They did, you know,
holy communion and they taught their
kids that they the equivalent of Sunday
school. generation after generation this
would go on until and like a hundred
years would pass and that living
Christian was still a Muslim at heart
trying to subvert and destroy Spain and
then that's why they finally kicked them
out. They said even if you convert it
doesn't help because you're lying. So my
point in telling you all that is that is
the level of that that you know you have
to deal with when you come to Islam that
there is going to be lies, there is
going to be pretend, there's there is
going to be all this. It's part of the
religion. Okay. So uh but having said
all that I still believe there's the guy
who comes from the Muslim world who
doesn't mean any of this.
>> He means you know I get that but it
becomes so complicated and so sticky and
at the same time it makes you ask
yourself why why do I have to you know
the burden of proof on me because the
only way to allow that guy to get away
with it is that I have to just let
everyone get away with it.
>> Okay so you
>> and then someone's going to get hurt. If
you had the ear of the leaders of of old
Europe, you know, I love that
Rumsfeldian fa phrase, you know, uh, uh,
France and Belgium and the UK, what
would you what would you tell them? You
have their ear. I would tell them, I
mean, look, the m the migrants you have
now, obviously they they are what they
are and you know, try to assimilate them
as best as you can, but no more
migration. Enough is enough. And no
more, you know, trying to force your
people and your culture and your
heritage always to like cater to the
Muslim. Here's another thing that they
don't get. The more you cater, the more
you cater to the Muslims and appease,
the more they despise you and spit in
your face. So do it from stand up just
from a practical point of view.
>> Okay?
>> Okay? Because they don't they respect
strength. They don't respect weakness.
When you show weakness and kindness,
that's not seen as kindness. It's seen
as you are weak. And to a certain extent
it's true that is weakness to act that
way. Okay. To step on your own culture
in order to make room for someone else.
That's nobody does that. They don't do
that. Right? So um it would be a little
more you know reclaim your heritage.
Stop oppressing your people and make
sure the ones that are there assimilate
as best as you can and keep an eye on
mosques because those tend to be the
breeding ground of um
>> I would say prisons as well. No
>> prisons too. Yeah.
>> Okay. Where can people find your work,
Raymond?
>> Uh, go to my website, raymondbrae.com,
and all my stuff, r a y m o n d i b r a
h i m.com,
and they can find all my stuff there,
books and everything.
>> And just to be clear, you're willing to
have a conversation. If I can find
somebody who disagrees with you, you're
willing to have that conver. I'm down.
Anybody anytime. Well, I mean, I don't
know about anytime, but yeah, I'll try
to accommodate.
>> Thank you. Thank you very much. Thanks,
Peter. Appreciate it. Thanks.